Protestants who say that Jesus wasn't
the son he became the son because 1st
Chronicles
17:13 is talking about Jesus and there
it says I will be a father to him he'll
be a son to me and now open up 1
Chronicles 17:13 get your Bible ready
let's go through this ready
yep okay when you get there read it okay
it says I will be his
father and he shall be my son and I will
not take my Mercy away from him as I
took it from him who was before you okay
now let's see what the context ISS go to
1st Chronicles 22 7
to1 First Chronicles vers 7 to1
okay okay now read it now guys what does
it mean that Jesus became the Son of God
I thought he's been the Son of God 1
Chronicles 22 7-10
right it says and David said to Solomon
my son as for me it was in my mind to
build a house to the name of the Lord my
God but the word of the Lord came to me
saying you have shed much blood and have
made great Wars you shall not build a
house for my name because you have shed
much blood on Earth in my sight Behold a
son shall be
born to you who shall be a man of rest
and I will give him rest for all his
enemies around all around his name shall
be Solomon for I will give peace and
quietness to Israel in his days he shall
build a house for my name and he shall
be my son and I will be his father and I
will establish the Throne of his kingdom
over Israel
forever okay so Solomon is the one
chosen to sit on David's throne and to
build God a house right yes and then
when he sits on the throne that's when
he'll become God's
son I will be father to him he'll be a
son to me right yep when when he sits on
the throne to rule right yeah now go to
Same Book 1 Chronicles 28 read
3-7 28 okay 3 to 7 go ahead says but God
said to me you shall not build a house
for my name because you have been made a
man of war and have shed blood however
the Lord so saying see the reason why
God did not allow me to build a house I
killed too many people which didn't
please God so go
ahead however the Lord God of Israel
chose me above all the house of my
father to be king over Israel forever
for he has chosen Judah to be the ruler
and of the house of Judah the house of
my father and among the sons of my
father
he was pleased with me to make me King
over Israel Over All Israel sorry and of
All My Sons for the Lord has given me
many sons he has chosen my son Solomon
to sit on the throne of the kingdom of
the Lord over Israel sit on the throne
of the Kingdom he's gonna sit and become
king when David dies keep going y now he
said to me it is your son Solomon who
shall build my house and my Courts for
I have chosen him to be my son and I
will be his father moreover I will
establish his kingdom forever if he is
steadfast to observe my Commandments and
my judgment judgments as it is this
day did you read all the way to seven
sir yeah that's to seven okay now do you
understand who the son is that sits on
David's throne and build God a house
it's Solomon right yeah and then God
says when Solomon sits on the throne I
will be his father he'll be my son
right mhm yes okay so understand what
kind of sunship this is talking about
correct yeah it's talking about being
the Royal Son of God the anointed Son of
God anointed to sit on the throne of
David on Earth on God's behalf and on
the day that you sit on it you become
God's son where as your father he
watches over you and fights your
enemies this is that kind of sunship
right yes but are you aware that before
Solomon became that kind of son as part
of the nation of Israel being
circumcised in E day he was already
God's son did you know
that no because what did Exodus 4:22 say
Israel is my firstborn son oh yeah
that's correct and Deuteronomy 141 what
does it say to the Israelites you are
the sons and daughters of the Living God
right so when Solomon was born and
circumcised wasn't he already the Son of
God in that sense yes but then he
becomes God's son in a different sense
right yep so he's the son of God as an
Israelite Born To The Covenant Community
because the nation is God's son the
nation he works through to manifest his
Rule and bring Nations to the god of
Israel but then he becomes the royal
king the heir to David's Throne sitting
on the throne on behalf of David and in
that sense he becomes the Royal Son of
God so he becomes God's son in two
senses he's already the Son of God by
being an Israelite Born To The Covenant
Community circumcised in eth day because
the nation is God's son then he becomes
a different kind of Son of God later
just like Jesus he's already the Son of
God in one sense he's the Eternal Son of
God who's been the son with the father
before creation but then later after he
becomes flesh born of Mary and a son of
David he becomes a different kind of Son
of God the royal son of God are you with
me yes okay now to break it down Royal
Son of God means you are a physical son
of David chosen to be the heir to sit on
the throne for
David if you're not a son of David you
can't be that Son of God and if you're a
son of David and you don't sit on the
throne you can't be that Son of God the
Royal Son of God has to be a descendant
of David who sits on the throne on
behalf of David right mhm yeah okay so
now now before Jesus became flesh listen
carefully because you're going to get it
before Jesus became
flesh as God he's Spirit was he the
Royal Son of
God in the sense I just
Artic no Jesus was not not the Royal Son
of God yet why because to be the that
kind of Son of God you must first be
what be born like an Israelite through
the line of David so only when he was
born of the Virgin Mary did he become a
son of David right yes then he qualifies
to be that kind of Son of God now now
why do you think Gabriel tells Mary the
following go to Luke 1 read
30-33 and then I'm going to show you
Hebrews Hebrews by the grace of
God okay it says then the angel said to
Hero not be afraid Mary for you have
found favor with God and behold you will
conceive in your wom and bring forth a
son and shall call his name Jesus he
will be great and will be called the son
of the highest and the Lord God will
give him the Throne of his father David
and he will re over the when did David
become his
father when he when Mary was going to
give him birth to him conceive him you
see and the Lord God will give him the
throne of his father David will give
him you caught it yes nice now he
qualifies to inherit the Throne of David
because David has become his ancestor
right yes now read reread Luke
13233 reread it and then I'm going to
show Hebrews and that's the answer okay
he will be great and will be called the
son of the highest and the Lord God will
give him the Throne of his father David
and he will reign over the house of
Jacob forever and of his kingdom there
will be no
end so you caught it right only after
the Blessed Virgin the holy virgin the
Theus can sees him he becomes a son of
David and he can inherit the Throne of
his father David right yes but when did
Jesus actually begin ruling as a son of
David when did that
happen um I I ass after his resurrection
you got it because when he rose from the
dead where did he
Ascend to heaven to do what
to um to establish you know to be the
ruler the king what is he doing where is
he is he standing or sitting come on no
sitting at the right hand ah so he went
to heaven and began sitting on the
throne that's the day in which he now
inherits the throne for David but when
do the sons of David become God's sons
in the Royal sense when they are in
Throne right when they the so when did
Jesus become
enthroned after his resurrection
Ascension to heaven so when he sits on
the throne in heaven as a son of David
is that the time when he becomes that
kind of Son of God yes exactly and
that's what Hebrews 1 said go to Hebrews
1 read three to five that's exactly why
it says I will be your father because
he's talking about a different kind of
sunship
Hebrews you get it y
so who being the brightness of his glory
and the express image of his person and
upholding All Things by the word of his
power when he had by himself purged our
sins sat down at the right hand of the
Majesty oh so after he died on the cross
and Purge our sins then he sat down on
the right hand of the Majesty on high Y
and that's when he becomes the following
so he sat at the right hand of the
magest and then what having become so
much better than the angels as he has by
inheritance obtained a more excellent
Name than they than they now let me
explain what it means he became better
than them in position and he
obtained greater Authority than them
because name here means Authority in
position he became better than them and
greater them in Authority because on
Earth he was in the status of a slave
and so now he went higher than the
Angels because for a season he was lower
than them in status so he inherited a
name meaning Authority and then Hebrews
quotes 1 Chronicles 1713 and Psalm 27
Now read it four and five next question
for to which of the Angels did he ever
say you are my son today I have begotten
you so when did he beget
him at the day of his enthronement you
got it it has nothing to do with Christ
deity his Divine sunship which he's
always had it has to do with his divic
divic sunship the divic Son of God the
Royal Son of God and then the second
quote and again I will be to him a
father and he shall be to me a son and
and of story that's first that's 1
Chronicles 1713 end of story